في المرة الثالثة ، لم يكن سحر الركاب
على متن رحلة من لوس أنجلوس إلى
ماوي ، عادت رحلة طيران هاواي رقم 33
إلى مطار لوس أنجلوس
الدولي ثلاث مرات أمس قبل
أن يقولوا إننا سنلغيها جميعًا
معًا ، وهنا لماذا هذا ما
الركاب على متنها  تلك الرحلة التي رأوها عندما
نظروا من نافذة وقودهم وهو يخرج
من الطائرة ، فهذه مشكلة ، نعم ،
لأنهم لم يصلوا إلى
ماوي ، لقد كنت قلقًا حقًا
لمجرد أنني كنت متوترة حقًا ، فقد كان
يصدر الكثير من الأصوات الغريبة
والقبطان  لم يقدموا لنا حقًا
الكثير من المعلومات التي تم طردها من سيدة واحدة
لأنها كانت مستاءة من أنها كانت مثل
رمي زعنفة طردوها من
شركة الطيران وتقول إن التأخيرات كانت ناتجة عن
أخطاء منفصلة وغير ذات صلة
بأنظمة مختلفة ولذا أقول
شكرًا لك أيها الطيارون الذين لم يحاولوا
إعادتنا إلى الأرض ، من فضلك شكرًا
لك